hello hello hello hello and welcome back
Sims and left go Sims vendrick how you
feeling I'm feeling great right you
feeling right feeling good
tell you what I'm very excited because
in our mascot battle I mean the trick is
now in and he has a piece of paper in
his pocket and it's a lot of notes
unfortunately you have no freaking
chance cuz you're a Seahawk I guess
we'll see we'll see clearly you haven't
done much research I'll tell you that
yeah Sims you feeling confident as an
eagle very very confident prepare as a
falcon how you guys doing we're doing
good how are you you're going to see
Hawk reddit not like the football team
like the actual animal there's she spent
some time there left oh if you want to
prepare for this battle today that's
alright Seahawk Redick yep answer for
everything in the planet literally
everything I'm like why it's in
Wikipedia Wikipedia where it's
user-generated stuff so it's not always
reliable but it's a lot of fun so do I
need to go on there more you pick a
topic and yeah we just taught you about
incognito windows you have a long way to
go man yeah that's a good one
so we got a lot of whoa big offseasons
we have some interesting Patriots I
watched two episodes of the All or
Nothing Cowboys I learned a lot did you
know those shows are great man and then
we are gonna have two guests on today
Chris long and the big Phil say the big
suck I'm excited for both of those guys
good good episode planned today it was a
good episode plan see how it turns out
at the end but let's start off with our
favorite coach in the NFL and gonna
start off with this photo now if you've
seen this they were at Bellator and it
is Kyle George the Kindle Cruiser 50
cent and Jimmy Garoppolo is that Kyle's
son that's Carter young named after the
young Carter what do you mean he's named
after low Wayne Carter
that's Kyle Shanahan named his son after
Lil Wayne yeah
that's that's how Cunha that's why he's
our favorite not after the president not
after a family after he was obsessed
with little Wayne my early years in the
NFL like Kyle's like one of those guys
that like if you're hanging and we're
drinking some beers or whatever yeah
he's got to control the music and he has
a DD so we can never actually listen to
a full song we listened to her like 30
seconds
a cool one my dad that was a cool suck
this ones you like this one better hallo
Wayne was played the MA my gosh
yes so he named his little boy Carter he
text message me a picture I got a better
picture of that with him in 50 cent hold
on let me show you what they're like
posing and I'm gonna I'm gonna show it
just give me two seconds do you know who
he was I don't know if he was like hey
you're the coach of the 49ers I don't
know that but here's here we go oh this
is the one 50 cent apparently put out
right here of college arms cross arms
cross posing with the little with Carter
in the middle doing it hello is Kyle's
daughter Beyonce doing what others kids
no the other ones are too they're all
normal names if you're listening Kyle
two minutes into the podcast we've
already got news I had known this kid is
named after Lil Wayne you know Chronicle
tomorrow I think that should help get
free agents to San Francisco no doubt
about it by the way this I saw this
online 2012-13 Kyle was the offensive
coordinator for Kirk Cousins 2015 the
offensive coordinator for Matt Ryan 2017
the head coach for Jimmy G since
February those are the top three paid
quarterbacks in the NFL pretty amazing
right he calls him a quarterback
whisperer
I don't know why all he does is make
quarterbacks really awesome but you
think you're called a quarterback
whisper when your offense isn't that
elaborate but your quarterbacks have
success yeah you're probably he's not a
quarterback whisper he's an offensive
guru yeah that's what Kyle Kyle is a mad
scientist a mad scientist yeah
quarterback gurus are guys like Bruce
Arians where it's like every Tuesday I
bring him an omelet and I tell him he's
the [ __ ] man hey that way he's ready
the the thing that will always like be
the big like thing for Kyle's career in
my eyes is the success he had been that
shop I mean he you know he be that
show-off was dressed right and in and
again you know he'll stick up for Matt
shop to the day he dies but I was always
like man Matt shop is so average and he
was like we can win a Super Bowl and
that's all of it and I was like yeah you
can cuz you're awesome and you have like
the best plays and football but you know
it's that's that's what a but good play
Clark caller can do Matt Schaub when he
graduated Virginia believe is the most
accurate quarterback in college history
at saw Eagles wanted to pissed me off
when I was early on in my career as you
looked at him and were like well Matt
Schaub played four games and got 60
million from Houston and I like led our
team to the playoffs and got two million
and like that it will piss me off to the
day I die
yeah but Matt Schaub is a good locker
room guy he can really prove are you
saying I wasn't you saying apparently
not let's go a lot of great stuff from
the listeners this past week a lot of
people I don't know if you've seen this
it's a movement are picking up Matt Sims
in there Matt and franchises and they're
just trying to get them better and
they're picking them up they're giving
him a nice 770,000 to sit on the bench
but everyone out there who's using Matt
and picking up Matt Sims it's a movement
thank you I love it we've had a couple
people win Super Bowls with Matt Wow
thanks for employing my brother I'll
tell him well they're not just employing
him one person sent us Matt in 2004 that
they picked you up and turned you from a
66 to a 90 thousands 2000 force that was
my rookie year I was a 66
apparently yeah and that's remember you
were the last pick of the third round
yeah that's that's nice two years
there's just these statistics they got
for you yeah over ninety eight hundred
yards passing and a hundred and one
touchdowns in two years sounds like my
kind of season you freakin killed it
yeah
I want to give a shout out our man Erik
Borgia down there in Australia yeah my
man keep battling we appreciate you we
love you very much
you can ask what up Dennis Alvarez thank
you so much for your service
man you guys are you're amazing and
we're happy that we can that you're
listening to AUSA jizz great what up da
one person did say they got upset with
me that we need to self scout yeah I
went on a rant got last year right Bill
Belichick has given up on the draft
remember he traded all of his picks for
four big-name players yeah none of those
guys panned out you know what I mean I
was like this is his big weakness and
he's fixed it right Kony Ealy Kony Ealy
was one of them yes Allen yeah didn't
quite work out Rex Burkhead I don't
think no that was assigning yeah that
was assigning but a bunch of
other trades and none of them really
turned into anything no they definitely
did not but it doesn't matter it was a
really good ramp like me though it was
well listen it doesn't I don't think
that changes your point I think that's
what he was trying to do right I don't
think it actually work no I I think he
realizes I mean I I know Bill openly
talks about the fact that he nobody's
blown more second-round picks in the
history of the sport than him like he's
not like totally meanwhile he had like
Jamie yeah he's had a lot of awesome
ones too but again the draft it's tough
men and Bill yes I would say if there's
a weakness to Bill it's probably that I
think it's everybody's weakness there's
too many variables
no one is batting a thousand in the jury
no no nobody's in about a thousand but I
do think that's his weakness I guess is
one of his weaker part gotcha because he
just they relied too much on brains um I
need to self scout you yeah let's go to
2009 whoa
here is the updated list of steroid
users from the 19 2009 New York Yankees
Alex Rodriguez Robinson Cano right Andy
Pettit Melky Cabrera yeah that means the
Phillies should have won that World
Series we're back-to-back World Series
champs you a noted steroid hater can you
admit now that that team was a bunch of
baloney I mean I never liked any of
those guys it's not baloney I don't care
I mean it doesn't matter to me I mean
I'm glad the Yankees won Phillies World
Series I don't care but yes it hurt your
heart when I got you never liked
Robinson Cano like Robinson Cano I'm not
gonna sit here and definitely say he was
on it at that point he was but he's a
cheater I mean there's nothing like
again hey I'm I'm sick of it I don't
want to hear from anybody anymore like
Mark Ingram whoever it is if you want me
to believe you I show me the paper from
the NFL to show me what you tested
positive for from then I'm calling you a
cheater I don't care as much as I like
you as a person but that's where like I
don't support a-rod screw a rodney's
grow up don't care yeah you know that's
where like I always look at it in like I
don't know it's I don't get New York and
Boston on you but New York never
accepted a-rod no they didn't where like
I was always a conceited by Boston but
so was Ortiz but it was like oh no but
you're still your clutch we don't care
no they played it but I'm saying though
the thing and we're getting too much
into baseball but he running Jeter the
fact that it was like
same position that was the issue - it
was like Jeter was short we got to move
a rod and the fact that he was there
next to him I always thought was part of
it what part of what like the fact that
like it was a similar position with a
guy like Jeter who you're never gonna be
thought it was everything he's just not
in New York nobody was ever like we were
glad when he helped the team out but
nobody was like oh hey rods he's a
Yankee for life I mean he was a high
support guys who go sitting on a rock in
Central Park with their shirt off to
pose for the New York Post no that's not
our kind of guy right Gabe kissing the
mirror I don't want that no all right so
this is a there's a big thing on the
internet today
whoa and there's no way that you've
heard it I am going to play a sound and
I want you to tell me what sound it is
are you ready yes okay what what word
was said say that one more time or no
yeah what did you hear Laurel Laurel
what did you hear Laurel I hear Laurel -
right okay so apparently do you remember
that thing back in the day it was like a
year or two ago where some people saw
blue and black dress and some people saw
a white and gold dress yeah those people
were colorblind but go ahead you were a
blue and black guy I - my eyes are
perfect so I saw bright whatever it was
I do remember totally so and I was a
blue and black guy to write you a blue
and black guy yes okay so apparently we
all have the same ears and eyes yeah
some people are hearing Yanni playing
again I don't think you're hearing Yanni
go to the doctor or the doctor or get a
cute dinner and clean your ears out
there are people at my desk that are
like I hear Yanni but when you play it
on your computer it sound like Laurel I
was like I don't know how you're here
anything else but apparently this is a
thing this is the thing let me play one
more time Jonnie Jonnie Jonnie i feel
like it's it's like a magic trick where
they've told a half of America without
me knowing right just say Yanni it's
fake news it's the Russians they think
it might be
did you know what Yanni stands for in
Russian no neither did I but maybe it
does I don't know I just want to see so
we're team Laurel tomorrow man there's
Laurel actual word though yeah Laura
like I don't want to rest on your
laurels oh that
I don't know how people are hearing
Yanni you know yeah I don't get it I
just wanted to see what side you were on
okay you have perfect years of perfect
eye so now my ears ever would say are
perfect my eyes are yes my ears are
definitely not between the the the the
medicine I use to stop my glaucoma
mm-hmm okay and just them being
naturally good my eyes are perfect take
a lot of pills a segment laughs go I'm
glad we did this
me too this is good did you actually
enjoy that no we're in all right so we
were super excited like breath values
like yeah they're great this weekend yep
brunch with him on Mother's Day they're
good any stop I don't have time to edit
we were very excited about fans and
gambling Sims came back with oh yeah
below all your savings account and all
that stuff
we had a guy Nathan Waddell a listener
from Melbourne Australia reach out yeah
and he said love the latest episode I
have some takes on gambling from you
from Australia where we've had gambling
legal my entire adult life the amount of
gambling advertisements and sponsorships
has become absurd to the point that
gambling addiction has become rife
throughout the country you can link your
credit card to your phone and live bet
on any line any horse race any rugby our
Australian Rules game it's like opening
Pandora's Box a little it's been amazing
and I'm a better myself I've won some
multi leg NFL bets from Sims s pic not
so much from left goes long but in
Australia where the standard of living
is a little higher gambling apps and
advertisements have ruined some poor
communities that's just a take from
across the Pacific all the best love the
podcast have been a keen listener for
years
MOA Thank You Nathan thanks Nathan might
it's definitely a little bit of
Pandora's box and I think it's going to
be interesting at the same time let's go
baby
is real we're gonna be amazing I've
looked at some of the lines it's left go
locks times don't worry about losing
your money because gambling is what you
need I mean I'm a little scared I'm
scared no because we have more low lives
in our country than Australia okay
I don't know Australia was like a prison
state well it doesn't mean anything
England why he's too smart we want to
get him out of our island no but anyway
keep going though what were you gonna
say tree of Ireland and Austria you
think Americans are even more degenerate
gambling yes justice if we have more of
just more people more cultures more I
mean yes this is what really scares me
is people that can be labelled as let's
say just the lowlifes I'm hanging onto
their last dollar here now we're just
gonna say blow it blow it all on Giants
verse Cowboys on Sunday night you don't
know crap about the game and you don't
know who's really hurting who's healing
healthy there might have been an injury
report but that's all [ __ ] here goes
your last savings and there goes your
little daughter going to college oh the
Giants and the Cowboys were worth it
it's good like I think if you are
already a degenerate gamblers so you're
opposed to legalized gambling I don't
think it's gonna be good for our country
gotcha now I think it's definitely I
think it's great anything that's like
great for business where you no longer
have to worry about the morality is
probably that it's great for the rich
white man once again the owner it's
great for it's great for companies like
us it's great for the league's it's
great for corporations because there's
gonna be an influx of money that comes
in but the ability to control yourself
like for me if I had to bet before I
text my one friend and then he would
talk to his bookie like I'm just gonna
be open and like that's how I would do
it yeah so it was more like okay I have
a few more steps now it's gonna be click
this button like for me when I order
Starbucks on my phone there's no place a
bet while you're at it it doesn't open I
don't know duh I don't have to enter my
credit card information and I know that
I'm just like reloading more money but
I'm afraid I bet I'm not even joking I
don't even need to bet you know I can
get emotionally invested in a game
without money well let's do the thing we
are gonna be doing our bed of the week
from now on we are embracing gambling
yeah I have all of the odds for the
Super Bowls and I think that we should
pick one
so when ice little futures bet to get
the officers but I think that we should
pick
team that we think is gonna win the
Super Bowl right now let's jump on some
betting and I am going to start off let
me just pull all these up so you guys
can see the odds we're also gonna be
doing we're gonna be even left goes LOX
during the World Cup as well so if any
to gamble on world football left go will
be doling out gambling advice all right
I love you can see that okay the world I
want you to just look at who because
it's not just who do you think is gonna
win the Super Bowl but what odds do you
like for me I've come down to three
teams Jaguars at twenty to one Saints at
eighteen to lanes is the one I look at
Chargers at 22 to one yeah
Saints is the one I look at right away
and go what eighteen to one how are they
the seventh team on that list behind
Green Bay like that son Green Bay in my
opinion is too high and the Niners are
way to ya the Niners I'm shocked at
Vegas said the nine 31 total nine and a
half I mean I'm you know that's my buddy
and I'm rooting for him but damn I even
thought that was high no I think it's
the corrupt the Garoppolo buzz right and
then also wins like over Jacksonville
look a lot better all right so you're
gonna go Saints Saints and can I do one
dark horse like it I'm just saying like
I feel sure what's the Giants the New
York Giants are at oh you're gonna love
this 33 to one baby the Giants are the
one like if you're looking to strike
gold that's the one I look at and just
go the Giants could be that worse the
first type of football team this year at
least am i I'm goin Jaguars at 20 to 1
yeah Jaguars if we're gonna keep saying
that they're the best team in the NFL
yeah and I'm getting 20 to 1 uh right
and they've added weapons on offense to
their line tight end wide receiver and
their defenses back now and I'm not
taking 20 to 1 odds they're they should
be so much more favored than the Packers
it's crazy yeah but they have Blake
bortles at quarterback that's the reason
that one's ahead of the other Green
Bay's ahead of them right the three
Bay's at 1401 I mean that's insane yeah
the Jacksonville roster I mean if
Jacksonville had Aaron Rodgers it would
be like they're going for a 7 Pete they
listen everyone 220 I mean exactly right
exactly and the only thing I'll say with
Jacksonville is just Jacksonville and
bortles and the way they play lends
itself to close football games right
you know the AFC South is good that's
all anything there but they're still
gonna be in one of my favorite team I'll
just look I'm betting on the team yeah
that had the ball against the Patriots
up ten in New England with the ball with
San was a seven and a ten point lead
you're like the fact that the Jaguars
didn't go to the Super Bowl is insane
yeah up ten with the ball ten minutes
left
insane insane all right all right I
don't have to play this one on my phone
um this is gonna be an audio one I don't
know if you've seen but the reports from
training camp are starting to come in
for the quarterback Josh Rosen its
former guest to the podcast Mike silver
it's a big time this guy's been pushing
papers and sign-in checks but he's been
able to evaluate Josh Rosen he looks on
Rhian thanks for the clarification at
the end that it's a good sign that he
looks unreal because a lot of
quarterbacks when they look unreal it's
not a good sign so I'm glad that he was
able to distinguish between it but he is
now the number two quarterback on the
depth chart out of Mike Glennon first
team reps yesterday should we start
talking Super Bowl
I mean is he better than Brady today I
mean this is a new thing this is a new
whoa this offseason that's the second
time it's happened yeah we saw it with
the Jets the front office guy went I'm
not someone that evaluates Talent and
then gave three paragraphs on valuating
Sam darn of course front office guys man
what are they gonna say you know we're
really regretting it Mike if you could
talk about that a little you know we're
gonna lose you I know
exactly right it's what it's hilarious
all of it I will say there was a whoa
big offseason from the Arizona Cardinals
that really excited me early Steve
Wilkes talking about Dave Johnson the
new head coach of the Cardinals yeah he
looked outstanding today it's good to
have him back flying around out there
yeah the things he's doing right now is
pretty exciting right I am very excited
for Dee I miss David John's of course
that was the injury that kind of started
it all for me he was a weak one
so was Alan Robinson like we lost those
two guys and got one yeah he's uh with
unquestionable unquestionable not I
don't even know what that means he's
without a doubt I wanted the best
running backs in football I mean yeah
he's a younger little younger version of
levian Bellamy that's who he is I mean
he's really he's probably every bit as
gifted or if not more gifted than
Le'Veon Bell I mean III think so
so yes he's a difference maker for their
football team it's gonna be different
offense for them this year - I'm Mike
McCoy Mike McCoy I think you'll see a
few more traditional sets I know they've
talked about like fullback in the
offense more there in Arizona I know
David Johnson was excited about that of
course he is and I love David Johnson I
do too there's also one of those guys
when you meet him you're like are you
really that nice and slightly corny oh
you are yeah like you don't have to
worry about him at all all right we got
another wall big offseason these are
always my favorite guys as you're
watching your team get covered the
late-round love stories media people
right now cover the undrafted free
agents and the seventh round picks not
because that's where the news is because
those are the guys that could get cut so
if you do stories on them now they're
still relevant right if you wait two
months they might not be on the team and
that's also some of the propaganda like
back to the front office that they will
push because that really makes them look
like I found the guy who drafted this in
the fifth and six and saddened and
undrafted like we're a little better
than the rest first whoa big offseason
love story tough off break upbringing
Broncos linebacker Josie Jewell raised
tending a hundred and thirty cattle and
18,000 turkeys and a lot of corn says
Jule you have to do stuff with
repetition you got to do it day after
day if you don't want to do it you got
to do it his college linebacker coach
says he's ultra competitive like ultra
ultra competitive
watch out Josie jewel was raised tough
on a farm and he's bringing that
attitude to the NFL Oh tough on the farm
farm guys are normally a step above the
rest hey you know Phil Simms as a farm
guy there you go nobody can milk the
uterus the utters better than Phil this
deaf guy yeah I didn't know where you're
going with this kid is a mound put them
in its
do you have any country bumpkins and
your teams I the I mean if you want to
be like real real about the NFL and have
real talks I mean the real the real
question would be show me people who
came from good upbringing z' in the
locker room that would be the real
question right well here's chris since
he came from a stable household with you
know a mom and a dad and he had money
and when he asked for it he got things
for christmas he's a spoiled brat look
he's in the NFL locker room he made it
though the locker room is just full of I
mean troubled stories people having
tough upbringing white or black because
yeah it's either hood or country yeah
and a lot of the times neither one of
those elements have a ton of money or
being spoiled I don't want to sound
insensitive to any of course my dad's
from the country yeah and I've spent
time in the hood with my friends and it
just yeah I mean that's really where you
come to it is more than that more not
like my best friend teammates I mean
their stories their upbringing it's it's
phenomenal that they made it to where
they may have they're all special it's
special it's it's a part of the reason
again where I fight so hard for football
players and then getting paid you know
it's just because you've chosen to
social injustice stories we'll talk
about well you are a spoiled brat so I
got another whoa whoa big offseason
offseason Hall of Fame comparisons for
fourth round pick stuff give it to me
and also a double-double combination a
coach homework assignment Rod Marinelli
has been known to have players study
former stars
he had Cowboys defensive end and fourth
round pick dorrance Armstrong study
Chris Dolman to which after watching
some clips Doran said he was a really
good dude
I feel like I can get into that and be
like him so here we are fourth round
pick he's going to be like Chris Dolman
do you feel it me or no he was doing
this with the Bucs we were there I mean
marinelle he's a great motivator so I
watched that Dallas young right and he
was showing Bulls running into innocent
people and being like juices how you
have to be that's what he was famous for
like I told you like when he had a
grudem
him do the team meetings every now and
then always had a great video whether it
was football related or like I told you
animal related he was like animal
battles he was showing like leopards
lions killing animals like this is the
way the defense has to play I mean
that's and it's funny cuz all the
players as he was showing it we're like
oh my god I know it's amazing
people do all that just don't cross the
line I think I've told you this before
don't cross the line and say we're going
to war or battle but Marinelli cuz he is
an army he was Nam and he'll tell you he
held his held one of his buddies in his
hands as his head blown off like it's he
had a lot of visual stories with in
terms of motivation he's an animal guy
and that's what I saw on the on the show
animal guide no nonsense Jesus left oh
he is like our kind of guy you should
send him some of the mascot battles see
what he thinks we should get him on just
away no I'm Marinelli they made me do
like a wish list of like every team and
they were expecting me to pick like dak
Prescott no my number one guy was Rob
Marinelli yes because I saw him walk at
training camp and I was like who is this
person it's like an aggressive waddle
he's like he was a nut he is when they
had Greg Hardy remember he was over
these again Mr D most defensive lineman
I would rather talk to nuts than
polished quarterback imagine being a
d-line coach I mean we got to something
we could ask my dad about d-line that
group of men that you have to control
the strongest people on the planet
they're all crazy if they want or
overtake your room and beat the crap out
of the coach they could do it in one
hand that's why I was about to do that
to Dirk totally on this show and dude it
was an issue yeah we're gonna get into
okay
okay last wall that was amazing though I
also realized looking back at year 2005
I forgot you guys the the buck signed
Chris Hoeven for that season for his
home and he was amazing on the Vikings
amazing because he was really a great
teammate one of my favorites or no he
was like where was Chris Hoeven from I
think he was from like Minnesota but
went to Boston College something like
that speaking of animals though yeah one
of the big whoa big off seasons for us
last year was all of the guys that
watched that documentary on Netflix and
gave up eating
meet Ryan they all went vegan right well
guess what
whoa big offseason Theo Riddick is still
vegan now is he like Adrian Peterson
vegan where he's still gone literally
wrote never forget when Adrian Peterson
said he was 80/20 vegan but then
admitted that he was driving past
Church's Chicken and said damn that
three piece looks good so now I'm 80/20
vegan and in the article ended with he
also admitted to getting Dairy Queen so
I'm like you 60/40 80/20 vegan also
known as not a vegan what do you say I
caught myself like 66 percent vegan I'm
probably a little higher than that but I
just know if I'm necessarily vegan I
want to say just no meat okay I would
just say your obsessive compulsive and
you eat the same thing every day if we
wanted to bring math into it yeah yeah
you eat plant proteins yes you eat
chicken right and that's really it yeah
and the guy had burgers last night I did
three burgers you're a big 80/20 80/20
yo Riddick said that he feels fantastic
he feels younger maybe it's because they
just drafted a running back in the
second round so he's trying to get that
out there
interesting Lions running back stories
Ameer Abdullah came out the other day
and said I need more carries right well
you know what well you need to stay
healthy they haven't done he was asked
though Thea Riddick
what does he miss the most what do you
think he said steak he said a ribeye and
then the the columnist wrote in his eyes
III don't think any NFL player should
totally go vegan I know no like it's
it's you need some of those animal
proteins to build your body the iron
from stake there's vitamins there that
need to be had to a degree yes where
where I have always started this it's
just because
yeah we're obsessive with meat and I'm
not saying you got to go vegan out there
but we don't need you know at the end of
the week going man I ate 21 hamburgers
and seven steaks and four pigs for the
week you know this is apparently our
health segment I would say that we've
become we have really weird
relationships with certain categories
and I feel like we're in the protein era
right now where everyone thinks that as
long as it's high in protein it's
healthy for you and these are people
that are not exercising no
yes the world in : case we're gonna call
Phil but I just want to say really quick
I watched two episodes of All or Nothing
here's what I took I'm gonna keep
updating so if you guys are watching at
home first thing Stephen Jones runs that
first often front office yes 100%
yeah and Jerry Jones is very involved in
the coaching like every Monday he's
sitting down there and there remember
when Zeke quit on the Denver Broncos
game he was sitting there going I don't
think you guys understand the [ __ ] that
this man is going through right now like
to the coaching staff like he's down
there we're calling felon she's perfect
boy did they want Paxton Lynch oh my
gosh
and then Jason Garrett and dak played
that target game at practice that you
always talk about two points for the
face one point for the chest
oh hello Phil Simms how you doing man
I'm so happy that you're here how you
feeling dude hey man I got a big pain in
my neck a pain in my shoulder who did a
dear Reggie white Mark Gastineau who was
it we'll go get him wait and a pain in
my ass so you know who it came from my
kid not me though just deer during that
right daddy no you know you were an
angel hey when we were on the phone last
night did you know your other son was
down in the kitchen trying to set the
house on fire I just saw the video no he
was saving my wife from burning the
house down
Dirty Diana had a bad night at cooking
huh well you know the amazing thing is
is she was cooking I heard that you
interrupted a Mother's Day speech what's
the story here yeah you did when we were
about to eat mom was saying how great it
was for everybody be here and he said I
don't know this is the best time to make
a Cheers announcement or other mother's
day my dad from this standpoint my mom
was amazing through let's say my first
20 years of my life three meals a day
my dad was a useless father all he did
was worry about football as God
swing but she retired like around my age
of 20 and dad doesn't have to cook a lot
I'll say that I'll stick up well the
good thing about Phil cooking a lot is
he forgets when he ate so he's just
constantly cooking this is the second
breakfast well you know listen then I'm
not gonna argue I have to breakfast is
basically everyday stop it what's your
first breakfast what's your second
breakfast my first one usually is one
avocado with I'm trying to trim up a
little okay two full eggs and about
seven or eight other egg whites I cook
them put them on top of the avocado
squeeze some lemon ought to eat it
delicious and then I have and then he
goes damn that didn't even make a dent
on me
I'm starving still and then so what's
the second breakfast I usually try to
wait one hour and try to watch and
listen to people on TV read articles so
you're tiny
your size the wait an hour is these like
this and then I usually have oatmeal
with a scoop of almond butter
blueberries almond milk and man it's
just christopher nolan's that come from
a big family and Adam you do too so we
ate what we called filler food so it
would be one night it would be cabbage
and potatoes and corn bread just a fella
something that would be the meal so well
whatever but so for breakfast man
oatmeal you know eat a big bowl bowl how
to get you going for the day and so I
grew up on it and Rob you know a lot of
people don't like it I love it
Phil I want to I want to test something
I'm gonna play something and I want you
to tell me what word you hear okay okay
this is yeah this is what you hear Phil
yeah what did you hear Phil nothing
nothing yeah
see here Phil whoa okay team Laurel team
Laura dad worried sigh explain to him
what's going on in the Internet
apparently some people hear that and
they hear Yanni they hear Yanni
yeah but yeah this is every now and then
like these I don't know if you remember
like the he might remember this do you
remember the black and blue dress that
some people thought was gold and white
okay all right well yeah that's alright
but that's alright you some people even
in our office are hearing Yanni out of
that and it's become a huge internet
internet sensation we're like half
people here Laurel and happier Yanni so
the fact that this is turned into an
internet sensation
it just says everything right there you
know i people say to me all the time
well first of all let me go regress a
little my dad looked at me once as i was
home from when i was playing and I was
eating and he just you know his her
famous say it was damn boy unless he and
he goes I hope I live long enough to see
the data to three hundred pounds and I
said man I got too much pride to buddy
300 but yeah you know what I'd like to
wait 300 just for the joy of getting
there man it would be a lot of fun it
would be a lot of fun my god where's the
data you can't really look let's just
get big Phil you can't wait 300 because
you have an NFL career to have I was
upset you were in here last week because
Kurt Warner apparently came out and said
that he was trying to play at age 47 I'm
a firm believer that I think you have a
stronger arm than Kurt Warner right now
do you think you have a stronger arm
than Kurt Warner like if you and Kurt
went out Kurt Kurt Warner went out to
the field and we're throwing who could
throw it harder
well there's no question I could I agree
yeah not the one to start but you know
could I throw as many passes him now no
you know I'm good for ten throws okay
I'm curious I want my lower back bothers
me but but I know this I could throw it
better than anybody underhanded so
oh that's your skin oh that's his thing
like one team he throws a few over hand
and people go oh Lin did you can really
throw up and then he goes oh well watch
this and then he starts he can throw it
like 40 yards underhand and really throw
a spiral it sounds like a totally don't
sell me short brother I can throw it 40
yards underhanded on a head high the
whole way it's pretty impressive what
yeah he can really throw it underhand I
start bouncing around you move right you
move left and there's people in the way
you just as I rip it underhanded and
they all go aw dang you know their
course they want to try and I said you
can't do it man I'm the man you know so
that's what it's come to it's not
golfing it's not football under I'm the
king of the underhand that's me that's
what the way my life is going and that's
just I don't care
dad's amazing the crowd though what else
does he I mean like you know he kidding
no he comes from the non videogame era
so dad like ping pong he will whoop your
ass
even if I drop that kill blow up Josh is
pretty damn good but you know shooting
pool on the table let me just go play
for a week or two we'll see who's good
you tell me when Phil I'll be there Josh
I'm just promising you almost slam it no
matter how you hear that that's what you
think once you see my spin comin over
the net you're gonna swing and miss is
so quick and it gets over there nobody
can return yeah I'll believe it when I
see it just makes this crap up I would
ask the same question to you about me I
don't really know you that well
but you know I know young kids
overestimate their ability all the time
yes they do you're right josh has been
beaten in this office already so we I'm
throwing the challenge occasionally
occasionally I'll drop a match occasion
ever we're back Evan back game and I
beat them but I'm gonna I'm gonna
$18,000
but in between those what the first game
we ever played a backgammon he I haven't
learned the game we bet $100 I mean he's
got come on we I told you the game you
put two one that smarter let's go we got
back some action well Phil I wanted to
make news so you can throw it harder
than Kurt Warner you know are you making
a comeback to the other side it's on a
thing for tendrils line up and just
stand and rip it yes I got 10 M he still
I threw about this is great five or six
weeks ago my son Matt was working out
and as I was warming up and I grabbed
the ball and I started to sauce it's
pretty good so I said okay I'm gonna
start throwing a few more and all of a
sudden I started really throw him and
he's looking at me going damn you're
you're spinning you're ripping it and I
said yeah I feel good you're not through
one of it ok that's it we have a 3-way
mascot battle for you to judge today oh
here we go
here are the representatives I am a
falcon your son is an eagle and josh is
a Seahawk it is a three-way battle so
again no bias well first off I'm just
gonna start right away yeah I mean
listen you've got to make an
unbelievable and not too long you know
we won't be long but yeah but I mean the
eagle yes be prepared to be amazed
have you ever seen an eagle in person
yes ok see you're already buying mommy
just start off with my eagle just to get
it over with I know what let's hear the
bias from all right you actually have
notes so the Eagle we just started off
with this I might just rest my case
after this sentence perfect I literally
[ __ ] eat you guys for breakfast ok
and I feed you to my kids
ok I feed you to my mate that I mate
with for life where I my mates so smart
we're so good at teamwork too I mean we
build nests that are 2,000 pounds okay
that like structures that cannot be
blown down by any weather force but
forget about that whether it's my beak
that can just grows throughout my life
that I actually have to carve down so
you don't use to attack other birds yes
I'm apart I know I used my absolutely
one bird that uses their beak and it's a
falcon so continue your point they eat
wood they're their beak what are you
talking about I'll explain you don't
know my bird okay and I eat you all the
time so I and my talents I mean I eat
baby deer so I don't really know what
else you guys want to say go ahead well
I'm not enough no bias how do you feel I
need you have an open mind josh is going
next I've prepared a few notes for this
if that's all right I mean you don't
know longer than Chris Nick Nick give me
the track if you if you don't mind Phil
do you hear that sound it's the deadly
chirp of the most formidable
indestructible fiercest bird in all the
animal kingdom the miserable czar elite
these birds two feet tall with a 6-foot
wingspan giving them the physical traits
to outmatch the wimpy four foot wingspan
of the Falcon and the heavy head and
heavy beak that slows down the Eagle but
let me tell you about how these birds
attack their prey they have reversible
[ __ ] toes they can stab forward they
can stab backward with their talents and
then when they connect with their prey
Seahawk talons close faster than the
human eye can even blink it is true and
this is a true fact everyone see Hawk
prey upon seeing the Seahawk just lay
down and die they just surrender
they don't even fight Phil I rest my
case the Seahawk wins the battle of the
birds all right here we go the Falcon
first I'd like to state that this is the
peregrine falcon you can just forfeit
but you don't have to do this I don't
think you guys are ready for what I'm
about to say one I'm going to say that
if you go online almost every major
zoologist has stated that in a fight
between a falcon and and eagle the
falcon wins Phil I'm going to be honest
I'm not worried about the Seahawk I'm
just going to neglect it completely the
Falcon is the fastest animal on earth
the way they attack is they sky into the
air and then they dive bomb at 200 miles
per hour and you know what they attack
Eagle
sometimes they attack what they need to
they hit so hard that I looked it up
I've never seen them attack you show you
all of the ever seen no they know hard
at 200 miles per hour that it is often a
fatal blow to the spinal cord of that
Raptor I don't think you guys realize
that's what your birds are actually
called now here's the deal Phil if that
doesn't kill them they get stunned the
Falcon is the only Raptor that rips its
preys throat out without a struggle the
only bird to do it through the most
actually eater like one pound there the
round agile they fly the highest throat
of a four rounds fish oh my god here's
the thing about Eagles I know that you
guys get really intimidated by its eyes
and beak it's actually a very docile
creature the Falcon is actually known as
the angriest so it's the angriest it's
the fastest and it's the only one that
rips throats film Wow let's hear what
you got so take some time
you never know angriest meanest all that
I really like that a lot I do and I'm
not feeling good today but two morons or
I've actually picked my spirits up a
little bit yeah there you go
and I'm gonna go with Josh I mean listen
I'm going with Josh just because he had
them well what's the word he had the
balls to stand up to me think about
darts you play darts at all what's that
you play darts at all I can't believe
this yards
I mean come on Sarge what are you
kidding
come on oh yeah oh let's go drink some
beer and then throw some darts and no I
don't play darts we do what do you mean
we use darts as weapons and I was
growing up and we saw them and stick
them in somebody just cause we wanted to
I will do will do ping pong and pool
then I don't feel like our judge
listened to our case very good but Josh
for his stand against me and you know he
added some music and you know so come on
I'm giving him props production matters
good
no me but you know real well in there
but I see what you got no shot against
me in ping-pong I'm just I've only seen
him lose one time in my life that's a
new to my cousin from Kentucky who's
like you know he's not a Sims he's got
another last name but he's he was
amazing whenever I play your dad let's
make sure cousins in town so that he can
get on the table after I'm a 25 we're
gonna come up to the house at some point
in the summer we'll get you up to the
Sims manner like Ospreys are considered
Seahawk that's what all my facts were
about what I heard that I was like then
that's the bird that's over my house all
the time and no jokes praise the town
like their tote they have reversible
tote so they can go back and forth its
own amazing Birds pretty messed up I'm
not even kidding I'm a symbol for the
country I mean strengths are we're just
waiting for a phone call now no I'm
trying to understand he's truly
disappoint one the fact that you put in
music and you had bird sounds under the
music yeah was the hardest that worked
on this podcast and quite sometimes I
put a victory on the board for me thanks
well okay dammit we think in live stream
for that ping-pong match yes I actually
think so I do think though that phil
simms throwing 40 yard lasers underhand
would do totally well on the internet
probably would yeah it's a target pretty
amazing let's uh yeah let's go shoot it
well get oh you know what I you know
what annoyed me today just they're off
since we're waiting for Chris long well
yeah is the the best part did you see
that Ethan Hawke thing about Knicks
games speaking I just yeah I just wanted
to my head actually is the Ethan Hawke
said he used to be a Knicks fan but he's
not anymore
because they don't give them free
tickets well then you were never offense
exactly that's not how it works that is
some
Hollywood like spoiled brat crap root
for refused to give free $7,000 tickets
which first of all I was like damn he
mean he's big-time buddy in like that'd
be they put up one clip of him in
training day and then he waves
afterwards he talked crap about the
Knicks and I guess Dolan heard it on the
radio so the next time he close that's
interesting though he just think can you
root for a team if you're like Jerry
Ferrara you're like the Rangers suck at
the Rangers like you're never allowed to
come to our games could you still be the
fan of the team yeah I could I mean I
I've been on New York radio and talked
crap about these teams a little bit and
yeah but if you were just a fun they're
like you can't come anymore well it's
not yeah yeah I would still root for the
team I would actually make me root
harder and then I would just root
against the guy who's not letting me
that's a promise he's the one getting
although the money yeah I know but it's
still you can't be a fan of the team and
sit there and go oh okay they don't give
me free tickets anymore I can't root for
them he called to ask for free tickets
and they're like no there's seven
thousand dollars and he's like wonderful
why are you making me pay and he says
he's not a Knicks fan I just think
that's some bull crap yeah we're very
loyalists to like actual fans yes
because like fans like the Browns fans
have been through a lot
oh my god so in today's eye I think I
kind of want to do new segments but I
don't know if we're gonna have content
for it every week are you sure he's five
minutes ladies in a call at 2:35 perfect
I want to show the difference each week
between Bill Belichick and Hugh Jackson
because I don't think there's a bigger
gap than those two people Hugh Jackson
is one and 31 in his last 32 games
aljalja jack is the greatest coach I
ever coached and I think the fact that
they're existing in this world at the
same time we need to show that gap do
you have a huge accident story you're
about to share yes go for it so let's
start off with Bill Belichick Bill
Belichick is such a good coach he's so
far ahead of all of us that he is
currently throwing random jersey numbers
that don't mean anything on players in
practice one of their rookie
quarterbacks was throwing in 58 the
other day why so that none of the
reporters know who is who and they can't
get out scouting reports apparently they
got in trouble for this two years that's
awesome but they're doing it this year
I'm looking on
I'm seeing quarterbacks throwing wearing
58 he's just the best just messin with
me he messes with everybody he does and
it's that's why Bill Belichick's the
great now the other side
huge accent right just announced that he
will in fact be swimming in Lake Erie
because they went they didn't go Oh in
16 they didn't go 115 they went o in 16
right so he's spending his time jumping
in a lake Bill Belichick is so far in
the weeds but Hugh Jackson the reason
that he waited until now because Browns
fans are upset they're like I wanted
this the last season to die his excuse
was the doctors he has a stent in his
heart yeah and he had to wait for the
water to get warmer yeah I mean I know
I've heard people complain about this
dam we want him to die too when he jumps
in the lake was amazing I was looking
more like oh what a wuss he's gonna jump
in at Lake Erie in June it's gonna be 62
what see he is I look at it and went if
I had hit in my heart I would use it to
get out of everything your wedding on
Saturday I'm sorry doctors say that I
can't go to weddings on Saturday that's
not a kid he's doing it for charity he's
raising money yes that doesn't know
we're mad too because they were like I
guess other Cleveland Browns
organization members every but it's
every coach that or every other member
of the organization it's another hundred
dollars to Hugh's foundation I heard I
saw some things on you know internet
yesterday that's what he but the fine
it's his charity so he's spending time
or guys I don't like Bill Belichick
thing either though I'm celibate I am
I've had enough of it like yeah don't
turn on him I don't care I just got to
keep it real with him sometimes I know
he's the holy grail of coaching and he's
the man but you know then again he's
gonna get mad that we questioned him or
ask questions about a player well we
don't know who the [ __ ] it is so we're
asking you questions cuz you're the
coach we don't know
it's I understand because it's like next
level stuff but it just I don't know I
get I get sick of that stuff a little
with him at times
you're turning on Bill Belichick I'm
just keeping a real I'm just you know
again you know he's he's got to keep it
professional too sometimes he doesn't he
expects everybody else to keep her
professional except himself the times
and that drives me crazy I wouldn't mess
if I was like him not coming out and
talking after you lose the AFC
championship games and things like that
like come on no I'm not
not gonna give it just a free pass cuz
you're the man and the greatest coach
ever that doesn't mean you just get a
free pass in life Boston fans hey yeah
yeah that's okay I'm just kidding but
there is there there now all the guys
that are willing to take on the Patriots
apparently you are now going to do that
well I don't want I'm not gonna just
give him a free pass always a big oh
this is amazing I mean he's amazing we
know he's the smartest coach ever it
kind of sounds like this is what Lane
Johnson said Lane Johnson came out I
think he was on Stone Cold Steve
Austin's podcast is amazing and he said
here's what pissed me off the Patriots
obviously I respect their coach I
respect Bill I respect Brady but just
because the way they won the Super Bowl
is a patriot way is that how everybody
else is supposed to do the same thing no
it's not and that's what I got mad at
the arrogance by them they were there
was obviously some stuff behind closed
doors their owner was talking [ __ ] to
our owner Bill was talking [ __ ] to Doug
Peterson before the game I'm not gonna
say it but a lot of stuff kind of builds
out like that I got tired of hearing
about it man honestly so you and Lane
Johnson are in the same boat yeah it
just it does get old a little bit I
would love to know the crap talk in
there I mean yes they like bill was
really talking crap to Doug Peterson
doubt it or maybe he made us not like a
snide remark or something like that I I
mean I don't know I don't know I have a
hard time with that I wonder if like
Doug got in front of the team like
before hey it's like you Bill Belichick
was out there and he said that you guys
were classless morons like what I mean
that ID yeah who knows oh really does
know but yeah again I mean I just love
that Lane when you beat the Patriots in
the Super Bowl it's your one time like I
can talk crap to Patriots fans all the
time and there's not a lot of teams it's
really Eagles fans and Giants fans that
can go hey Patriots we beat you in the
Super Bowl and everybody else is like
god you're the Holy Grail you're
incredible yeah and I thought about I'm
like who really has taken on my patreon
Giants have done the big two back there
yeah you guys want on some interesting
plays we outright beat the crap all
accounts the same to us
Rex Ryan very willing to take shots at
the Patriots over the years yeah I feel
like for Rex Ryan the Patriots were what
the Cowboys were too buddy Ryan well
yeah I do I honestly think John horrible
this is my own
start with the Patriots of course I'm
not gonna doubt them he's the greatest
coach ever I do think there's issues up
there right now of course there is what
I know I mean there's issues I think it
is I really do because I just I've had a
few friends and people with yeah III
think there's a true little bit like of
an actual dislike of Bill Belichick and
ghrelin right now yeah we got someone on
the phone News Chris log what's up Chris
log I'm doing great I'm doing great just
getting back to work in Philly yeah
what's going on you guys have workouts
today yeah I just got done in my first
week back in town and next week we start
you know OTA patches so it happens fast
well before you get out serious I just
wanted to ask him what his workout is I
was trying to break him in nice and easy
I want to know what his work yeah that's
break him with this we just had big phil
simms on oh yeah we know your dad really
well we've talked to Howie so many times
it's he's like I can't even imagine
being raised by Howie because I that's
the reason you guys are so awesome but
did you have any experiences with Phil
Simms like did you know Phil at all yeah
I did I didn't know and obviously it's
rare for my dad to think real highly of
a quarterback you know he talked about
fellas
well he's not he's a great quarterback
you know Super Bowl champion you know
all this stuff but he's not really a
quarterback with with his mentality and
that's what I respect about him so I
always when I met Phil growing up I was
like he's a dude and I and it's true
that's what he is and you know he's a
football player and that's what I think
it's pretty cool about him super bro
yeah he's just challenged just of two
ping-pong Susan kick as I do I admit
that I'm an Eagles fan and that I love
Lisa and that him having his kid there
on the NFC Championship game was the
coolest thing ever and that ended the
drought of my life should I do that no
just kisses but Tom awesome he is let go
I think the coolest thing about Chris
and I'm gonna speak about you in the
third person is not only were you one of
the main vocal white guys that stood up
and helped the movement going along
everything that you've said the entire
season
it was like what I've always wanted a
football player to say and then you win
back-to-back Super Bowls with different
teams like I do what you've done these
last few years is incredible and I know
that you had a lot of patience with a
lot of those Rams teams over the year I
just want to say congratulations man
thank you I appreciate it man you know
I'd like to think it always comes back
around and it evens out but I'm just
lucky I know a lot of guys played longer
than me and never got dismissed a
playoff so I never complained I never
was like I feel bad for myself I just
stay patient and I got lucky
well you didn't get lucky okay we know
that I see you definitely did and that's
something that I mean like for all those
listening out there I met Chris when he
was training coming out in the in the
NFL draft version he trained up here in
New Jersey at Parisi's so I would see
him there a lot right and he was you
know ended up being the number two pick
by the st. Louis Rams and kicking ass
there but that's where I want to start
Chris just like talk to us about your
experience and choosing New England and
then having the guts to basically tell
Bill Belichick like hey I really enjoyed
it but I want to move somewhere else and
I feel like fits my skillset better and
then just tell us about your experience
in Philadelphia and how it was different
than New England if you can yeah no
doubt when I finished my eighth year
with the Rams you know for the first six
years of my career and st. Louis I was I
was on kind of a roll I was doing well
um you know I had about 50 sacks well
had 50 sacks in six years I you know 46
in four years and was definitely if I'd
have stayed healthy there would have
carved out myself a nice little career
there I don't know that we've ever got
over the hump we never won more than
seven games and after a while that kind
of wears on you and you know year seven
I'm kind of in my prime I get rolled up
on in the first game of the season I've
never missed the game before and I tore
some ligaments in my ankle and had to
get surgery and really should have been
I are came back late in the air looked
off
then busted my ass to get back to close
to 100% to get ready for the start of
the next year by eighth year and third
fourth game of the season I'm getting
back into it and I got rolled up on
again and broke my tibia so again same
thing couldn't fight the urge to try to
battle back a little bit early I came
back and I looked like absolute trash so
if you know from playing hurt nobody
cares and they forget pretty quick that
you can still play what's wrong why were
you happy yeah yeah I don't know I'm
trying to rehab during a season right so
you know and and that's okay I mean I
kind of had a feeling that going into my
eighth year it was a make-or-break year
for me with my contract I was making a
lot and I for year and a half there two
years I've been hurt so I was released I
didn't take it hard
I understood that the ranch had to go in
a different direction and fish is Jeff
Fisher probably coolest got to get
released by man he called he called me
and I think he's the only guy that you
can hang up the phone and smile after
the relationship yeah and he's just he's
just a dude like that and I looked at it
I had some options I said my phone rang
a lot surprisingly I got five six calls
right away but I kind of was like listen
I don't want to play a ton longer and I
got to feel like what winning feels like
and there's one place that I know that
it's going to be in it at the end of the
year and that's New England and when I
talked to Bill the first time you know
is one of those things where he's like
listen I can't guarantee your role I
don't know what your role is going to
begin
but I kept carrying there was if you're
talking to people and they tell you
exactly what your role is going to be I
don't know they're going to be
successful and that's kind of the mantra
there is you have to be adaptive you
have to be able to kind of fly in blind
and and that's why I didn't have a
chance I didn't see myself as having a
real position on an outside background
our three technique right
yeah I'm not a five and under so we'll
see where the chips fall and when I got
there
early in year we run a lot of kind of
4-3 type stuff and um first couple games
a year I was really kicking ass and then
there was a lull where we were playing a
lot of defense and I was down to three
technique and I was doing my job but I
wasn't making a ton of plays in there
and so playing three technique most of
the year got kind of old we get to the
playoffs I've become kind of a third
down rusher I had a productive year
rushing efficiency wise and end up
winning a Super Bowl obviously the whole
28 to 3 thing
how was one little tidbit in between
they're just so like what is that like
for you who's played one position their
whole life and now ok yeah you were
losing when you were playing that
position but you're being asked to win
play a different position like just the
you mean was it hot when you have you
know were you excited to go to work and
practice every day did it take an extra
physical toll on your body having to
play a position I think it placed a
little bit of a toll just fine by nature
of the position being more physically
demanding for a guy who weighs 260
pounds
you know depending on the scheme of the
team we played I thought I could do it
pretty well but it's tough when you're
taking on doubles and those sorts of
things and I got my ass blown off the
ball a little bit sometimes it's just
that's not what I do and I enjoyed every
moment of New England as far as my
teammates the coaches you know I like to
go a lot and the fans were great I still
talk to a lot of my teammates there it's
a really it really is a special place as
far as what they've been able to sustain
over a long period of time it's not the
only way to do things but they do what
they do well and and I enjoy going to
work there but at the end of the year I
kind of saw my role trending down
towards just the pass rush again I still
want to play football and I had this
joining when I left st. Louis my number
one each was to try to win and secondary
to that was to try to get back on the
horse and be the same player I was or
close right and you know north of 32
years old it's hard
do but I decided I would take it and so
I didn't know that I didn't know that uh
whether New England want me back or not
I you know what I looked at their their
roster the year after I left I mean you
would think they might just because they
didn't have a ton of pass rush and that
type of stuff but I didn't want to waste
Bill's time and I just I just said hey
listen man like high priest you know I
wouldn't have a ring without you and
I'll always love my year here but I got
a I got to give it a shot to try to go
back and be the player I once was and
you know it was just like I believe I
believe in young thank you for
everything this year and you know I
believe if that's where your hearts at
you should go do it and so that was I
was Philly for me and I looked at Philly
and just said I'm not gonna check I
called it but I knew we'd be pretty good
I didn't know we'd be that good right
but when you looked at Philly last year
they were one of those teams a year
before last
as I was evaluating that they were one
of those teams that was hot early in the
end yeah fizzled out right and there's
always those teams in the NFL but a lot
of times that team is just growing up
where it's close but it's not quite
there and and identified the way they
play defense aggressively schematically
it's at what I did and I know why
gunshots yeah so so I I called Philly
ironically and I didn't get any calls
coming off to New England I had to call
Philly yeah so so I called it Philly and
how derozen was like yeah we could use
you yeah locker room guy you know that
type of thing and I was like okay that's
not really what I'm trying to do but
okay I'll just come play it out right
and showed up and played pretty well and
ended up carving out a little there so
Billy and can you believe Chris that you
get to play next to the 69th best player
in the NFL and Fletcher Cox and his name
is [ __ ] it's remarkable when I saw that
pop up on my timeline I thought it was
like a one of the the onion articles you
know like Cox makes number 60
we've we've also we liked doing
we like standing next to each other a
practice right long time you saw the
pictures yeah well now we have a rookie
named sweat put them in the middle I
don't know where we put them but he's
sweaty [ __ ] combinations well I mean
you know we've got plenty of good names
on our team and we'll have some
surprises this year as well what just
just if you can though you know like you
hit on it a little just okay so you go
New England you win a Super Bowl
Philadelphia you win a Super Bowl from
the outside looking in and I think from
the inside looking out we all know that
that's two different type of
organizations and the way you guys Lane
Johnson's to talk about today on a daily
basis so like what was it like going
from New England where of course it's
very regimented and strict to a degree
as compared to Philly where I'm not
saying you're not Regiment in a strict
but it certainly seems a little more
free to the players well they're
different places I will say this you
know you guys I've shown somebody else's
stuff I never once had anybody in
England and I'm gonna do Kummer there
that stop me or pulled me aside and said
you can't say this you can't do this
so you know there's a lot talk about you
know New England and the culture how it
is day-to-day there one thing I will say
is you know no one ever told me what not
to say and tonight I appreciate Bill and
those guys there and and I just think
they're just different I mean whether in
any pro sport there are multitude of
ways that you can run your organization
and that's the same in business I'm sure
and at the end of the day different
teams succeed you know Seattle is very
different than New England as well
I mean Seattle is a player two away from
being kind of a multiple championship
type of organization which is so hard to
do in the NFL today you know New England
has their way doing things you know they
also about the greatest court
back a long time for you know going on
almost two decades so sometimes you're
like is it the way you do things or is
it the players you have and I think when
you have like a great culture and a very
consistent way of doing things and then
you couple that with good talent
evaluation what's the perfect storm
Chris Lilley yeah I was just say I have
a pitch for you yeah what do you say
everyone's still asking who's going to
the White House right it's a thing yeah
you send two people you and Malcolm
Jenkins
and you walk up and you go hey we're
here for that conversation you keep
promising all these teams just you do
you think up at the White House yeah
just you to know I'm not going I mean
even if I was told that you know there
was a there was an opportunity to sit
down with the president or something
like that having the idea of the
president listening to a player and not
the American people there's kind of
Chile in its own right so and I also
want that a lot of those and a lot of
those meetings or lip service anyways
you know you've seen different leaders
from different communities don't meet
the president before and nothing changes
it ends up just being a a net gain for
the president and writing that well I
met with these athletes and I listened
I'm just kind of going go and do the
same thing listen at the end of the day
I don't want to sit and take a picture
with somebody I don't care for
it's a photo-op and if it's a meeting I
think it's kind of silly you know that
the president would not listen to the
American people and again listen to a
pro athlete on a one-off basis well
you'd have to give him the Al Pacino's
speech in any given Sunday Sims person
Crist we do not know what to say really
Chris said on Twitter that that was the
best sports speech in a movie ever
the Pacino speech like one more inch and
any given subdue today I can't even
remember the speech to tell you the
truth so it is that I spotted
you know a days it's a good speech the
movie is wildly unrealistic yes so it's
every football movie right I hate them
not the program without the program is
the worst frickin football movie ever
the worst the probe but the program
crosses over it is such a realm of being
unrealistic that it's funny right you
know where some of these movies you know
you have hands company is that what it's
really like no are you kidding me so
drafting was realistic I can't go out I
catch a lot of [ __ ] for this but I don't
I don't like Remember the Titans I'm
shocked Sims are you big the Titans
you're sunshine well uh yeah you might
want to say that sure but yes I thought
that was a pretty good football movie
all right I just want were on this
subject real quick we're like if you
heard Bill Belichick was gonna sign a
guy that was really narcissistic plays
places blame on other players on his
team never takes accountability and is
all about me me me would you be shocked
at Bill Belichick signed that type of
player Bills Bills gonna do what's best
for the team at all times I think that's
what makes him so respectable so if he
is wanted Chris I mean what the hell I
thought we revived in here but I
understand how bill can support Donald
Trump because I just feel like to me and
I know people up in New England feel the
same way it's a little hypocritical that
he preaches all those things and yet
he's gonna support a guy that does the
opposite of what he really preaches to
his football team well you'd have to ask
him yeah and that's the thing is in
unless pro athletes or coaches or public
figures are speaking out on why or why
not when I asked to me less you might
what you haven't given a single reason I
don't have to repeat the thing that I've
already said all you have to Google do
is google it but yeah yeah you know it's
it's hard to debate anybody and if they
don't tell you why or why not yeah
that's right I guess my question is you
were saying this before I never thought
about that of why are we listening to
pro athletes as someone who clearly can
think outside the helmet and can see the
social ramifications of their actions
where do you think we are right now in
terms of interacting with athletes and
understanding athletes from just a
general population standpoint well so
there's a caveat here because I'm a part
of the players coalition which was
started by Malcolm Jenkins and Anquan
Boldin and you know there's a group of I
don't know the exact number I think
we're around 50 players that have used
their platform to work to pass
legislation to open conversations to you
know fluence you know proxy process
brutal races things like really earth
things change and that's kind of the
answer to everybody's question is like
well gadget me or guys are speaking out
what are you doing about it and then a
group like this is like really pushing
to make substantive like legislative
change or influence people educate our
population on some issues and use their
platform people are like we'll just shut
up a played football so that's kind of
the cycle we're in so I do think there
is something positive to listen to
athletes unrelated to the Trump thing
the Trump thing is kind of on an island
of its own because I I think I don't
think he listens to anybody so it's less
about you know a pro athlete er it's
just why waste your time but as far as
pro athletes are concerned I think we
have an opportunity here because most
country watches sports and most of
country isn't willing to I say most of
the country there are people who voice
their opinions their boycott boycotting
football whatnot but most people are
going to at least have to hear our takes
on the things we believe in as citizens
and a lot of times what we get is the
stick to sports thing you're not allowed
to talk politics and my responsibilities
wealth and you're gonna have to stick to
whatever you do for a living which would
make for none of us would talk politics
you know right unless your legislature
unless you're unless you're going to
work every day at the State Capitol you
should probably not tweet about a bill
being passed or a political issue so you
see where that gets we'd be
stock we're all American citizens were
asked to take ownership of our
communities and to be role models that's
what I was told
remember the whole Charles Barkley thing
growing up sure you know I'm not a role
model and he caught a ton of [ __ ] for
that okay so we're supposed to be role
models well do role models just do like
turkey drives or toy drives like is it
just the stuff that you think is
mindless enough and that we can all
agree on
that's it does some good or what if we
really dig in and try to improve our
communities so that's the question
that's where we're at I think we do get
a lot of credit I'm not we're not like
it's not a hard line to tell I mean we
get a lot of positivity as well but I do
think we get a lot of flack as well it's
it's yeah we are we call ourselves the
players podcast because when it comes to
contracts people think you guys are
overpaid when it comes to expressing
your opinions they tell you to stick to
sports and we're just trying to explain
to a lot of people the human element
behind it and the vast array of humans
that are involved you're one of my idols
Chris long I just don't know that he
really is because he's as a player
saying and doing all the things that I
would have done if I was a player at
this time especially and I just want you
to know I really no fear Reese well I
appreciate that but what I will say is I
think it sucks to that you know I think
what I'm doing is just to bear what
should be expected of players is if you
think something's important you should
speak on it and I wish what I was doing
wasn't relatively remarkable you know
what I mean yes so I hope more players
you know and it's not to me that there's
a ton of guys I know I else in the room
was on white but there's a ton of guys
that probably feel the way I feel that
might just be rightfully so worried
about their employment I worried about
the backlash or whatnot
I think once you cross the threshold of
I'm just gonna say what I what I want to
say employment began and I know I made
good money and whatnot I'd like to think
I'd be the same way early in my career
but I would rather be me then I have to
find that tunnel time so that's just the
way it is yeah do we have a nickname yet
for this defensive line grouping of you
Fletcher Barnett
Bennett like this incredibly do we have
a unit name yet
uh who I don't we don't have a nickname
and you got to be careful with your
nicknames because back in st. Louis when
we had and the st. Louis group was
really good is that like a Leonard
noodle
no no so it was Robert Quinn we had like
nineteen sacks one year of myself in my
prime quote unquote and William Hayes
who one of the most underrated defensive
ends in the league at the time
Langford Michael blockers Aaron Donald
man all these guys Aaron Donald by the
way fast efficient player in football
yeah can you annoys her nickname though
yeah so so so we we were pushing to
break this a corrected for I mean we
were up in the fifties easy and we would
talk about breaking the sack record game
the next year going in that year in the
summer st. Louis County dubbed us you
know sack city was the big thing
everybody was talking about sacks it
everything was hashtag sack city all
this stuff and it all fell apart the
next year you know so you're
superstitious now we went yeah we went
like six games without a sack something
like that and from there honestly that
group never was the same and we all kind
of left the free agency and getting cut
so I'm not a guy so no nicknames just if
he wasn't an eagle fan he'd come up with
a nickname for you but since he is and
now you've talked about you know in fact
I don't even know your name what's your
name you've been awesome and stayed with
us for basically 30 minutes I got one
more question for you and I'm on a more
fun note first of all I don't know
however your mom fed all you people in
your house when you grew up
okay but I want to know like if there is
any story you could share because of
course your dad is I mean out of the
cave he's a caveman and so is your
breather
and you're like a smaller caveman even
though you're tiny and they're
Neanderthals yes so do we have any good
stories of tussles with dad or tussles
with the brother where dad had to get
involved anything like that that you
could share cuz I just can't imagine you
three sitting at any table let alone on
a daily basis yeah I think in general
just mostly between my two younger
brothers Kyle and Hallie and my Ally
being a relatively young normal-sized
really athletic dude but he's a six-foot
guy and a family full of giants and that
made him absolutely fearless so Kyle and
him were a year apart they're Irish
twins and how being you know six foot
seven 330 they were called home multiple
times because they were in like full-on
fist fights at school well into out of
the age where it was appropriate for
that to happen like they were fighting
each other at school brothers oh yeah
we're talking about like dude you almost
have your license this has to stop you
know and early on our household was like
my parents we went to the ER so much
with my younger brothers because they
were just so accident-prone it was like
an episode of Jackass every day that
like they pulled my dad aside be ours
like is there anything you want to tell
us like like he's yeah it was like after
you get to you take your kids the ER
enough they have to pull you aside and
like like interrogate services you know
my brother would you know stitches
actually and my brother with a baseball
bat 36 stitches actually swear to you my
other brother broke his jaw you know the
other POW hit how he hit Kyle with a
picture frame 16 stitches across his
forehead if we counted up all the
stitches in our house it was probably in
the hundreds for sure yeah I feel like
how he was like oh like dad how he was
sit there be like that's my boy that's
he mad mad but proud at the same time
scared shitless all the time even now as
an adult dinner table together we get
together that once a year
he's a little nervous that's awesome
you the man doing this thank you brother
congratulations man well thank you thank
you so much for having me on
also look follow chris on twitter at how
do you pronounce it joel 9 yo it's just
joel joel 9 1 and then also water boys
org follow that on twitter
org that's the way the bringing clean
water to parts in east africa chris long
just continues to be a great human that
i know you don't want to be called great
but realize that then the line for
normal is much below where you are and
we appreciate it and that sucks but yeah
i appreciate it
you the man dude good luck with
everything thank you thank you chris
long good guy great guy like one of my
favorite families ever so i'm a firm
believer having met you right and i know
your dad that i see the way that you
live your life and it's very based in
routine yeah and based in routine that
you hold yourself to a certain level
every day you're gonna do what you need
to do to achieve something to have that
discipline and then also on top of that
go i need to do something else i need to
speak up so because it's very easy to go
I'm in the NFL I'm gonna do you know how
hard it is to maintain this and the
pressures that I'm under right a
physical toll that it takes right but
then still give my dad's famous and he's
on TV and I don't want to compromise
what he's doing because I'm saying these
things that are you know somewhat yeah
what would I want to say controversial
exactly right yeah and to be willing to
kind of put all that out there because
one it is different that he's white
let's acknowledge that yeah it's also
let's also acknowledge that as he said
he made a lot of money in the pre NFL
Draft is right however you're still
gonna put your name on it and a lot of
people don't and I think that's what it
was incredible with the Eagles this year
was everyone said oh it's gonna hurt
your productivity the Eagles won the
Super Bowl and were the most vocal team
in the NFL yes I know I thought ideal I
really want to come up with the nickname
of them especially because they have so
many guys do you like I know but it's
like told to it they're like such free
thinkers it's full of no can just call
them to freedom Flyers something like
that I just feel like an awesome
call them our guys our guys cuz it kind
of is Fletcher Cox Chris Long Michael
Bennett some of our guy yeah they are
our guys in sweat our guys cuz it ROG Oh
sweaty long [ __ ] could be our guys damn
sweaty long [ __ ] it's funny that any
time you know that Chris long saw the
Eagles draft and was like what last
names sweat Irving I can add that it's
like a madla Flyers are such perverts uh
speaking of that we can wrap up with
this panthers have a new owner
his name is David Tepper he has bought
the Panthers for 2.2 billion they makes
them around the 21st most valuable
franchise that means I have long said
that I believe that the way that an
owner has made his money will determine
how they run the team right how did he
make it he was a part of Goldman Sachs
okay he is known as taking very risky
investments okay and it's a hedge fund
guy so you know hedge fund guys I do
he's about money yeah he's about taking
risks and it could all blow up in his
face or it could be great right so it's
a little Jerry Jones where Jerry Jones
made his money and oil drilling this guy
sort of finding risky but interesting
plays and attacking them but there is a
story that I thought was really
interesting about Dave pepper apparently
he has a pair of brass testicles
cartoonishly huge and grotesquely veiny
they are affixed to a plaque inscribed
with the words the most valuable set of
all time and then in these Appaloosa
offices were it was the company that he
owns it resembles a sports bar all
polished mahogany flat-screen TVs and he
was a minority owner for the Steelers
many people refer to it as a wealthy
frat house one of his clients made
breast implants and he also would keep
breast implants on his desk and would
use it sort of like a stress ball for
now well when I think of the Panthers
owner I'm going to think of a brass set
of balls that he keeps on yeah he that's
gonna be against the NFL rules so he
better get that out of the workplace
conduct but I know that's kind of funny
I never I mean I don't like when cars
have balls on the back of them you ever
see
the cars have the paintballs I'm just
gross yeah guys thank you so much thank
you too Chris long things to phil simms
we have a lot of things now plan we
gotta go phil simms throw footballs
underhand
my pigs I'll get Josh vs. Phil in pink
I'm actually angry now now that that's
yet I just wanna go play him all right
I'm excited for Chris he's out homie for
everybody man we appreciate you guys
when you hit us up on social we try and
bring it up on the show
thank you so much for the iTunes
comments we're almost at a thousand
we're about two hundred guesses on the
Odell Beckham birthday bash and the
comments are hilarious look out for the
the plug there the game is obj contract
we love you we'll talk to you soon
enjoy your weekend
[Music]